so um what I'll do I will introduce the
system and tell you how we can actually
build a race of control control qubits
you know based on individually track
neutral atoms and I will also show you
how we can use a system to perform for
example not a qubit through logic
operations or to engineer large-scale
entanglement and in the last maybe 10
minutes or so I will tell you about the
kind of things which we are working on
now which involve scaling this system to
much larger arrays in two dimensions and
employing this ball for studying
many-body physics and to testing some
quantum optimization algorithms so in
our approach as already mentioned we
utilized cold neutral atoms which
attract individually using the so called
optical tweezers which are basically
tightly focused beams of light and we
focus beam so tightly that at most
each Twitter can host one hat and so
what we do in each experimenter and we
don't start with one tweezer but we
start with a large number of them and
then we just try to load them
simultaneously and this loading is not
perfect so the system like this has an
entropy and what we do to basically
eliminate this entropy is we just take a
picture of atoms and remove the empty
traps and then basically arranged the
entire atoms in the desired
configuration after that we can
interrogate this laser similar to what
Chris talked about this morning but to
make them interact we actually excite
these atoms into this so-called
read-back States States with five
principal quantum number in such a way
that the atoms fathoms which are
separated by even a few microns can
interact extremely strong and this is
our effort within Harvard MIT in front
of ultracold atoms as a collaboration
with flood and voltage and Marco's
grinders
so here is the kind of just simple kind
of high-level overview of the fourth
generation of our experimental apparatus
so remember that because I will have to
tell you about the second generation
towards the end of my talk and so the
key in this apparatus is this acousto
optic deflector this device which takes
an input microwave or radio frequency
tones and actually outputs arrays of
laser beams and basically then what we
do is we focus with a race and a vacuum
chamber and then we have two objectives
one is to basically projective strips
and another one is to basically take
pictures of atoms to basically figure
out which traps of who and which empty
and then what we do is we take a picture
activate a feedback loop and then what
we can do is basically kind of you know
do things like this we first take a
picture for example here of about
hundred tweezers and they are filled
with certain probability close to sixty
percent and then what we do we just move
each atom to form a kind of much more
regularly so this is actually
experimental team which originally built
this system so many of the members
already now a kind of prominent
scientists on they own have their own
groups like Marilyn and harness in
particular so in order to control
interactions as induce and control
interactions have already discussed we
excite atoms in their inbox States and
the reason why we like the rework States
is because they combine very very long
lifetimes like you know more than
hundreds of microseconds and very strong
interactions in fact the interaction for
high principle quantum number n sk is
like at xi power of n and so what it
means that if you excite for example the
atoms into the stage with an equals
hundred then the Wonderwall interaction
between the atoms will be 14 orders of
magnitude stronger than the interaction
between ground state atoms so 14 orders
of magnitude is a big number and we can
make good use of that so one specific
approach which we like to use is a year
Friedberg blocking so that's a year
which actually
we developed with Ignacio and Peter
almost 20 years ago and the idea is
basically Foulke so if you take two
atoms and you know for example try to
excite them into the break state
resonantly if they are very far away
then they will be undergoing individual
Rabi oscillations but if you bring these
atoms close then eventually this
interaction this very strong interaction
will take over and basically two atoms
within this so-called Reaper blockade
review so you know you can simply not
excite both of them simultaneously we
can excite one atom or another but never
two of them at once so this gives rise
to this effect of reedburn locate the
simultaneous excitation is blocked it
turns out to be a very effective
mechanism to entangle atoms because it's
insensitive to position atoms you know
so long as everything blockade it's
insensitive to motion and all sorts of
other things and so basically what
follows I will be showing some pictures
which basically will involve first you
know starting with random okay randomly
few traps first in one dimensions in two
dimensions and then basically preparing
these kind of arrangements of atoms so
for example in this cases are the blocks
of I guess six and then subjecting them
to various kinds of laser pulses and
then at the end
reading atoms in a certain internal
state you know so pushing you know for
example you know some you know of the
states you know out of the trap and just
measuring the remaining atoms so and
times its approach and basically the
film is platform over the last couple of
years you know our group and also others
have actually done a number of
experiments which basically involve both
quantum information processing but also
Quantic simulations and among the things
which we have done is we've carried out
experiments on high fidelity
entanglement and also parallel multi
qubit quantum gate so for example what's
shown is that to kind of measure truth
table of toefl gate so it's actually it
has
still some substantial error but it
turns out it's one of the very best
which has ever been done in many systems
so but we've also done a lot of work on
exploring novel quantum phase transition
exploring quantum dynamics and also a
kind of probing large-scale entanglement
and the point which I'd like to
emphasize here is all of these points
are very closely connected you know this
is all of these things with each other
so basically you know improving for
example you know quantum simulations
which often use kind of analogy dynamics
you know helps us to actually kind of
you know make digital circuits better
and the other way around and actually
what's important is up in this area you
know you want to deploy the best
techniques possible so in fact often
analog devices turn out to work better
and digital devices so and let me just
kind of give one example of that is when
we employ a system to use quantum
simulations of spin models so basically
here what we do is we prepare a string
of these atoms
you know if let's say equal seperation
equal distance and in cold qubits in the
ground and rebug States right downstate
all the atoms in the exact in excited in
one of three Buxton's and then basically
you know this is two-stage system so you
can write an effective spin communion
and basically this spins and Etonian is
shown here so it can be actually to
understand what's going on we can
characterize it using the the ground
state phase diagram and what is axis is
here are the tuning is basically that's
this term is a laser detuning and then
interaction range and you know like
first if we for example neglect the
interaction so what's clear is that you
know whether you know the change would
be in the lower Stella tronic stage or
in the rework state will depend very
much on the sign of the tuning so if
that you mean is negative then you would
like to have all atoms to be in the
ground
running state but if you flip the sign
you would like to have all atoms to be
eaten in burg state but steak like this
you know shown for example right here
that violates blockade constraints if
you turn the interactions and if the
interaction ranges is small such that
you block basically these nearest
neighbors so what will happen is you
will not be able to access this state
before what I'm excited so the best you
know what you can do you can create the
state where every second atom is excited
that's the so-called kind of anti
ferromagnetic state or you could say
that's a state with G two broken
symmetries just come down now if you
actually increase the interaction range
then you will not be able to excite also
second nearest neighbors so the state
you create halves if free symmetry
Brockman and it goes on and the way how
you can explore this phase diagram is by
basically just starting before atoms in
the ground state and just changing the
detuning the laser detuning kind of
slowly to try to idea might click enter
all of these phases and so that's years
ago and basically when radiation sees
how all of these kind of orders in
origin so basically with these different
cases here is we excited the same
rebirth state but what we have done we
just created traps where the atoms
expect closer and closer together so
here on the nearest neighbor is block
two it's up down up down down state here
second nearest neighbor blocked it's up
down down up down down and so on and and
it continues and what you see here is
that you scan detuning basically kind of
around the detuning equal to zero you
know have a lot of fluctuations and it's
basically when system does not know
which state to choose so we can really
study this kind of simple quantum phase
transitions at these walls so
but you know what's kind of really
interesting is to go to much larger
system size and you know first
experiments almost three years ago two
and a half we looked at the system which
had 51 atoms and you know so here is the
array of this 51 atom stream you know
before we have now let's kind of set the
distance such that we basically have
only nearest neighbor blockaded so you
should create a g2 stake but typically
one if one just does the ramp across
this transition you do not get a
perfectly ordered state you get this
kind of long string down and there is a
kind of a defect this is basically the
main wall you know then there is another
string and one can analyze now this kind
of phase transition by using
thermodynamic quantities for example
density of the main wall so variance of
the main wall six locations and what one
sees is that is basically really like a
classic signature of the idea of the of
the second order phase transition in one
dimensions were there and for the
parameter changes smoothly but these
fluctuations you know peak just around
the phase transition point this is
exactly because system cannot decide in
which state it wants to be in this case
and so basically you know in this very
first experiment so we basically already
have kind of were able to kind of nail
down this phase transition point it
turns out to be in a good agreement with
theoretical predictions by all condensed
matter colleagues by students are given
and quarters but there is much more we
can do so we can also look at this kind
of phase transition microscopical
because we can measure each individual
atom and what we can do here we can look
at a basically probability of each
microscopic you know state you know
curing and so in fact sometimes we get
this up down up down up down
of that state and in this very first
experiments it had cured we know the
finite probability but actually not
pretty small but anomalous this state
clearly here stands out and in fact you
know what I'll show you in a second is
that by now we improve the system such
that we can create the states with
actually pretty high in your property so
we can you know really quantify and
benchmark the system a little bit in
this way we can also look at things like
then students give choreo in terms of
course and basically what it really
shows that you would have you know kind
of unique set of tools to really kind of
get very interesting insights into the
physics of quantum phase transition
particular into quantum dynamics and so
this is actually what we have been doing
for the past you know a couple of years
so we have studied for example you know
critical phenomena are exploiting for
things like quantum people Zurich
mechanism we've also started studied non
equilibrium dynamics you know where we
would actually you know push the system
quickly across their face trans you
shouldn't see how it thermolysis and
actually in fact in these experiments I
would say that we made already one of
the first kind of discoveries real
discoveries with quantum machine we have
found some trajectories which are non
formalizing an ism by now known under
this name one too many bodies cars and
actually this is now a very active
theoretical frontier where people try to
understand when these many bodies cars
occurs was exactly the in nature and so
on so it's actually very cool kind of
but what I'd like to do to be kind of in
a spirit of these you know discussions
which we have I'd like to basically you
know explore if this kind of approach
can be used to benchmark quantum system
one way to kind of benchmark is to
create a large-scale entangled state and
so in particular one problematic state
is this kind of cat stage on your cake
state only state where it's basically a
superposition of you know all qubits in
one state and you know all qubits and a
kind of an orthogonal state
so these kinds of states are important
because on one hand they actually
maximally sensitive to decoherence so if
you can create this state you really
know that your system works very well
they're all very false for things like
error correction and communication and
metrology but also these states are very
relatively easy to correct right so
basically all you need to know you need
to know basically two diagonal and two
of diagonal elements other than
schematics you know of them and qubit
density matrix as shown here so from
those you can put together this quantity
called fidelity basically overlapped
with perfect state and actually that you
can show that if this value is larger
than 1/2 this is sufficient for
impractical entangle so how do we create
the state so we will use these diabetic
sleeps and but we will use the even
number of atoms so in this case if you
do a back sweep then basically you
should create the state which is
superposition of up down up down and
actually in practice it turns out that
you know if you just do that you would
also have some substantial a mixture of
both Friedberg atoms on the edges so
this state has very similar energy so we
don't want this a mixture and what we do
is basically we just apply like local
magnetic field effects you know
effectively what we do we actually apply
laser beams to these atoms to basically
push this state out of the residence and
then what we do is just to perform the
sweep and for the system of 4 atoms for
example you know this all of the states
of aerosol so you can just do that and
you can measure them
cubics and computational basis measuring
probability of both of these states
indeed if I probability have I were
up-down up-down or down-up down-up and
you can also measure of diagonal
elements you need to rotate the basis
and basically you know and measure them
in the different basis but what
specifically you'd like to do you would
like to verify the faith's
and you know if I the first you need to
control the face and we do it by
applying a standard magnetic field which
basically applies a magnetic field to
every other atom and it actually results
in the face which is picked up between
these two different components and then
you know to measure this we just rotate
rotate the basis and measure parity and
then we can have the fringe and we can
extract freedom right so it works very
well for for atoms but actually if you
go to slightly larger system like for
example eight atoms what you see already
start seeing this kind of spaghetti here
and basically you can still try to do
adiabatic powers but it's actually
becomes very very challenging so at this
point we think that if our colleagues in
we used one of the optimal control kind
of techniques developed by the masses
and Simona's group and actually this
optimal control technique while it does
not necessarily change any kind of
scaling actually does result in kind of
practical improvement so in fact you
know from through this we found some
kind of non-trivial pulses and actually
it results in trajectories which are
known not perfectly adiabatic but still
result in substantial speed up and kind
of high fidelity manipulation so so this
is for example you can prepare these
states but actually one I would like to
kind of emphasize is that you know
basically this technique works for
serious of kind of controlled I abide
transition and if you old actually
converted into the dueling shortage you
know this would result in a kind of
short keep depth twenty number of atoms
of product of Rome two hundred without
making any single errors so you can for
example estimate what's kind of
probability of yet error in our system
based on that and so fifty gigs like
this you know here are some results for
twenty atoms so basically this is the
probability of all states so we have
about you know million states and you
know this blue arrow we also know that
you know in our system the measurement
has some error so it's actually their
mirrors and this measurement was kind of
around maybe one half percent per atom
and you know by quantifying this
measurement errors we can in floor what
actual the actual probabilities which
you prepared these are this yellow bars
and we can also and you know this
actually weighs 225 so for example these
are experimental measure correlations
between all of these twenty items so
it's basically kind of these
correlations basically non became but
what we can also do we can also now
control the phase of this state by
applying the standard field and and
measuring the parity and basically from
these two quantities we can just you
know in Florida fidelity and what we see
is in details as we measure a fidelity
for larger and larger number of times if
abilities you know decreases but still
for 20 atoms we measure we have find our
state is entangled and you know this
actually is the largest GG state created
in a kind of programmable system today
but you know I think there are many
opportunities to improve this actually
we're continuing some of this work so we
know our main sources of noise it's a
laser phase noise would like to the
power optimal control loop I'll also
mention something about it at the end
and we are also exploring various kind
of echo and knowledge improvement
procedure so at the end what we'd like
to do is use the system to understand
dynamics
- distribution of entanglement and
perhaps even use of this section tangle
and to improve atomic clocks okay so
we're you know what are we doing now so
where is this going
so we have a number of exciting
directions I don't really have time to
talk about all of these but I'll give
you a little bit of kind of a sneak peek
into what sky so you know One Direction
is really to try to increase the system
size and you know and control you know
she's succeeding you know hundred
hundreds of units and you know the way
how this is done is by basically
upgrading their experimental so instead
of a coup stop deflectors in second
generation what we are doing is using
special light modulator so it's
essentially a hologram that you can use
to kind of deflect their laser beam and
you can actually kind of appropriate
that you can create rays of beams in two
special dimensions which you know then
you can focus in this system and you
know create arrays like this so sexual
thousands of traps extremely homogeneous
in this traditional square lattice
arrangement and what we do is we load
atoms into them and when we need to sort
them in the way how we sort them is by
using two crossed acousto optic
deflectors so basically can instead of
just moving them along one line we just
now can move them you know everywhere in
two spatial dimensions so and basically
so all can be more control to the affair
with AWG so here's some source drives
where we create about six hundred traps
and then load them and in this case you
know she again loading is probabilistic
and each trap is
human thought is loaded with about 60%
probability so what we would like to do
next if you like to basically and it's
loaded also pretty fast you know faster
than water so what we can now ask is can
we feel you know let's say 300 sites so
here are some attempts so here is
initial loading and here is an after
sorting and again what you see is that
this loading is working pretty well it's
not yet completely perfect so you can
see error you know once in a while so
actually right now each single trap is
loaded you know if the 99% probability
but of course you put 99 2 to the power
300 you see you know some errors but you
know never less know is you already have
can have this high probability load
basically perfect arrays and of course
this is here is an example of their
square ladies but you know by no means
we are limited by square lattice we can
create any arrangement in fact we can
create arbitrary patterns so here is for
example desire pattern which would like
to create and you know here is the
experimental image okay so what can we
do the system like this so now interest
a two-fold so what first off we would
like to do quantum simulations who would
like to explore exotic spin systems and
we would like to implement quantum
algorithms so let me give you a little
bit of of a sneak peek into both of
these direction so in the first project
what we are doing is we're exploring new
phases in two dimensional square here is
onion which we used already for one
dimensional system and so basically you
know what you could do now we can start
adjusting blockade so for example if you
focus on this interaction term if you
have like a short-range blockade so then
you will not be able to excite all of
the atoms in Reedsburg state but you
should be able to excite
like every other one of them Annette we
should create this kind of checkerboard
face you know this transition to the
state should be rising to devising a
phase transition but if you now start
playing for example with interaction
range with blockade range and it turns
out there is a whole zoo of there of the
phase and so in fact you know this is
long range interactions this actually
becomes a frustrated system so some of
these phases actually very exotic very
unusual like this rated phase for
example here and you know basically
about a year ago we kind of together
with subir and one of his students who
actually worked out the phase diagram
and what we can now do is explore it
experimental so note that you know this
phase diagram is actually quite soft and
quite complex or are some very
interesting new phases can be observed
but actually even this two-dimensional I
think quantum phase transition it turns
out has never been observed experimental
so in no other system and so that's
maybe the simplest faithful let's just
try to basically try to see if you can
see this I think you key on this square
lattice so what we'll do is we'll do the
same thing as we did for 1d system we'll
start with all atoms in the ground state
and just try to idea vertically and
third is this phase so here is the
arrangement so we fix a locate and
basically you know do this transfer and
what we see is actually you know not
perfect not perfectly order system but
the system orders pretty nice this
bridges pretty well so we can quantify
this ordering in several different ways
and for example you know one thing is
correlation and what you see is that
basically at this point you know the
system is ordered you know across a big
chunk of the entire sort of array
dimension so for example we can you know
just thinking at one cut that the cut
along y direction we can see that you
know this
relation length is around like seaside
so it means that it basically is
correlated from minus six to plastic so
it's actually correlated across nearly
the entire right and one can then now
study you know this phase transition for
example by looking at this correlation
length as a function of direct sweep
rate you know this is how one can study
for example things like chemo Zurich
mechanism so here you just change the
queuing the different rate across this
phase transition in this is some of a
very early preliminary data but we can
see already some very nice scaling and
actually if we extract scaling exponent
it turns out to be very very close to
their two predictions from like the
icing universality class so basically we
believe that we really have now you know
for the first time this I think quantum
phase transition in two dimensions and
actually there are many other
opportunities you know for probably nine
different types of exotic states so I
think we're just you know starting on
that you know stay tuned just one last
thing I'd like to kind of point out is
the connection between these studies and
things like quantum optimization so in
order to explain that let me kind of
remind you about one kind of pragmatic
optimization problem independent set in
which you are given a graph with
vertices and edges and the idea is and
basically independent set is a subset of
this vertices you know for example walls
which are colored by red such that you
know no two colored vertices has
connected by one edge so for example
what's shown here is an example of
independent set and M is problem you
know consists of finding the largest
independent set so it's one of these
problems is very easy to formulate
what's actually very hard to solve so
what is shown here you know is an
example of M is on one specific graph
it's called unique you
and which your tests are connected if
they had within a given distance so this
is a so-called this graph and actually
turns out you know and both in my ass
and particular if you need this graph is
actually a very important problem
because many real-world applications
design of networks machine learning
actually you know by looking by hearing
Google stock so it looks like maybe of
this tuning of you know qubits and
superconducting quantum computer might
be one you know related to this to this
optimization program but so this once
again is a simple kind of very generic
optimization problem but it's actually
the problem which is hard to solve so
you know so it is actually a complete
problem even finding exact Markham I
asked for this you need these graphs it
turns out to be np-complete
now if you listen you know close to my
talk you know there is immediate direct
connection between this Mis problem and
blockage so specifically you know if you
are trying to excite the atoms and there
is rhythm or a blockade you would like
to excite as many happens as possible
but you are not able allowed to excite
them we feel this brocade radio so it
actually turns out that this M is known
assuming these can particular these
corresponds to the ground state of
located on and the question is you know
can we now use our platform to try to
basically you know look you know try to
use quantum kind of hard work to improve
optimization so the ideas which would
like to kind of explore involve both
idea my determination you know but also
things like you and you know for both of
them there is a prior work and but the
question is how well will this will
perform any kind of large-scale coherent
system so here are some examples so in
this example we start
if they you need this graph on a square
edges with edges connecting us and next
nearest neighbor and you know this is a
corresponding graph it's you know still
relatively small problem so you can
solve it exactly you can find much
independent set and the way how we will
actually implement this in simple view
you know assemble arrangement
corresponding you know to the one on the
left and just adjust a big or a blockade
to you know basically you know implement
desired connectivity and then what we
need to do is simply you know try to
basically find the low-energy or ground
state you know system somehow right and
hope that it's close to there today M is
and so in this example what you see is
that it's pretty good but not perfect
you know so that's now look how it works
so there are two approaches to this one
is to use something like annealing but
actually we can do better because how
the system is coherent so we can use
this quasi diabatic so here is one
example where we basically just you know
fix the parameters of the sweep and just
try to kind of look you know what kind
of independent sets you create and what
we have done is kind of use this one
sequence with one timing on different
system sizes so here is example of 49 so
I just so exactly my sixth well front
you know would find it and quite
reasonable number of cases so 480 we see
we still finally but it kind of
decreases and and and and for 180 will
also find it but it's already a
probability is quite small so at this
point you know we are just starting so
for sweep fix with time we see that
probability to find is scales
exponentially but we have not yet
deployed all of these techniques for
example which we use to create a GG
state and
what we are trying to do to base with
optimal control closed-loop optimization
and so what we can also do is we can run
our system and a kind of more gate more
and more digital mode so actually to
implement QA it turns out we can just
use a sequential application of blockade
from atonia and the control parameter is
here is a duration of this communion and
also the phase of this of this driving
field and so here we start with a
relatively small problem just 35
vertices and in my exact time is here is
12 and you know the step with a step one
it actually doesn't matter which phase
you use but basically what you do just
perform this kind of quench experiment
where you just turn the commute onion
first certain time and you see that
there is basically an optimal times here
so you can you can fix this time and you
know you can try to see what is you know
what are the solution for here we cannot
quite find there a my ass still you know
because it's you know it's 12 we can
actually increase the circuit depth you
know and go to to be equal to and
actually at this point you know this is
one of the first rise we might we just
change pick the phase difference phase
change the face by PI over two and
actually what you see is in fact you
know it already improves performance a
little bit you know still attend the
performance is not as good as as this
was idea Matic speed but then again we
have not really done you know very much
up Tamizh ation and in fact this is what
we are working on now so so we are
trying to kind of look at you know
finding optimize optimize the angle
setting also developing closed-loop
optimization strategies and that an
actual also trying to do kind of more
rigorous quantum classical benchmark but
you know I think there are a lot of also
opportunities here you know
both classical and quantum error
correction won't be your you need these
problems and also we'll have some ideas
how to utilize his approach for
suffering I think I have used that my
time hasn't just point out that you know
last couple of years there are also a
number of new experiments I'm actually
you know really cool work which kind of
you know really covers a broad frontier
from any body dynamics to quantum
computing and metrology and so I kind of
stay tuned for for new results so I
think I use that my time you know here
is the summary of my talk and here is a
great group of people whose blood and
sweat resulted in all of these things
which I showed you and thank you very
much thank you
Michelle I think you very much sous-sous
are the questions
I have the great question you mentioned
the the maximal independent set
it's a np-hard problem on the on the
general class of graphs which was graphs
whenever Pharisees are separated by was
are they connected that separated by
like less than a certain amount of
distance but is that also is it still
and he can be hard when you when you
restrict the graph vertices to be on the
square lattice as you've done here yeah
it turns out it is yeah yeah this grabs
it turns out that to find so a kind of
general Amaya's problem for general
graph is np-hard and also to find an
efficient approximation as a pure heart
so this these graphs is restricted
graphs actually they are the exact
solutions is killin be heart but turns
out what one can have efficient
approximation and actually potentially
this might be kind of not a bad problem
to start with because maybe one could
see if quad quantum you know for example
you know optimization can improve
approximation ratios and stuff like that
and that's what we are trying to hi
Nisha this image so very nice talk I had
a quick question so let's say that you
know if it was much if you could do
certain computational things with about
the same number of qubit six hundred to
a thousand but you needed a 3d lattice
is that is that sort of easy or
impossible you know how hard would it be
to get there yes so yeah there is a very
good question so there are two ways so
we believe that a step from one D to two
G is kind of a big step
because it allows kind of to expand the
class of problems kind of significantly
so in principle you know you can also
assemble 3d arrays of atoms and you know
and this has been done maybe not with
the same degree of control yet but you
know it certainly is possible but the
other in a thing which I want to point
out is that you know and I hope you have
seen is that basically we are not in our
sort of models we are not restricted to
nearest neighbor interactions and so in
principle like even in a system which I
showed here with these three hundred
atoms we can engineer me nearly poor you
know all-to-all and corrections by
choosing the specific kind of set of
pulses right so and at this point is you
know it doesn't matter what's the kind
of dimensionality of the of the system
so I think both of these approaches are
possible and actually you know probably
long range interactions might be even
easier in a relatively short run but you
know but also you can certainly do a 3d
also yes and and if you if you do the
three eat and you can you have all the
you know say all nearest neighbor
interactions turned on simultaneously
yes yes absolutely yes
yes and the only the more technically
you know for example is 3d lattice
you'll probably be a little bit more
challenging to to kind of you know feel
and also to image but you know and
principle everything the rest of the
physics is all the same okay so there is
somebody asking a question that to my
understanding without is currently
completely destructive do you foresee a
solution to this or would one rely upon
a reservoir of sacrificial and sealers
yes yeah one can do in fact yeah both of
this the answer is yes on both
so we are on one hand we can have this
additional and cos which we can bring in
you know and you've seen on some of the
images but actually it turns out that
you can use this blockade mechanism also
for very efficient Q&D readout and which
actually Magnusson to be in q ii can be
much much faster so i would say them you
know like at a high level the weakest
part of both i'm and adam approach is
that readout is slow it can be very good
but you know it's certainly in our case
we can do gates you know we can do gates
practically to give a short speed but to
do the readout it you know requires you
know kind of millisecond you know
typically you need to collect these
photons and this add and this other
approach which actually were just
finishing a paper on this and decide
approach what we do we basically use
small ensembles of atoms to read out and
the idea is that you know if you
basically have you know one single in
purgatory
you know in the reebok state it can
actually block transmission through this
food is cloud of nearby cloud of atoms
so and in this kind of final
architecture one could imagine that
there could be basically some you know
it kind of individual arrays like
individual atoms as shown here and will
be interspersed by these kind of little
clouds of atoms which kind of act like
trend transducers for it out and in the
case these things have to still be
developed but you know basically in a
recent experiment we have seemed kind of
95 or so percent success probability QE
read out within ten microseconds
thousand times faster than usual so I
think it's very promising approach also
so I have another question in is little
rivet to the other talks so you have
mentioned this wonderful experiment on
with hundreds of atoms in two dimensions
and
you have been able to see this phase
diagram and so on and I'm wondering to
what extent for that particular result
do you need two hundred atoms or three
hundred atoms could you have done the
same thing with fifty three could you
have done that with Google's quantum
computer well it's well I don't know but
you know but at some point for example
what we see for the simulations is that
you know the edge effects for example
much more severe in two dimensions right
because for example you know hundred
atoms you know in one dimension right
the edges you almost don't feel them
right but you know like hundred atoms in
two dimensional has only a linear and
dimension of of ten you know and
actually in fact we are still trying to
understand for example in this
correlation lengths and so on and what
we see is that this edge effects even
for our system size are very very
important so many atoms for that exactly
so you need them you need many you need
yeah I do think that you need hundreds
of atoms to have at least a shot at
extracting things like thermodynamic
quantities and so on and and you know
also entity cool if you start looking at
more exotic states like spin liquids and
so on which have entanglement there I
can imagine that this also this edges
will be very very important you know
edge you know go edge States and things
like this I think besides all the stuff
that people think about my Ana's for
example they would like to have edges
right well separated okay some seem to
be the case and so let's think again for
his talk and all this because of these
sessions were these wonderful talks and
me sure you have some time there are
some questions that you may answer
online soon frequent in the soon okay
and otherwise I will just say please
come back tomorrow for Theory Thursday
we have a theory
Wednesday excuse me we have a slightly
shorter program today but equally
high-quality all right okay thank you
have a nice day afternoon evening night